قرار مفاجئ يرافق دخول الحرب في اوكرانيا
شهرها التاسع عشر يعين الرئيس فولودي
مرزيلينسكي السياسيه رستم اوميروف وزيرا
جديدا للدفاع خلفا لاوليكس وهذا بانتظار
مصادقه البرلمان على قراره
قررت تغيير وزير الدفاع الاوكراني لقد انت
اوليكس اكثر من 500 يوما في الحرب الشامله
اعتقد ان الوزاره بحاجه الى اساليب جديده
واشكال اخرى من التفاعل مع كل من الجيش
والمجتمع برمته اتوقع ان يدعم البرلمان
المرشح رستم اوميروف روستيم
رشح جلينسكي النائبه البرلماني اوميروف
وهو مسلم من تاتار القرم حيث كان عضوا ضمن
لجنه التفاوض الاوكرانيه مع روسيا وكان
يراس صندوق املاك الدوله منذ العام الماضي
حيث سيخلف رزنكوف الذي تم تعيينه قبل
ثلاثه اشهر من الغزو الروسي وقادم مفاوضات
كييف مع حلفائها لتسليح قواتها بمعدات
عسكريه حديثه تاتي اقالته في ظل الهجوم
المضاد الذي تشنه كييف وبجوار الحمله التي
تقودها اوكرانيا ضد الفساد بناء على طلب
الاتحاد الاوروبي تغيير منصب مهم في
اوكرانيا يرافقه امر بالايقاف لشهرين يطال
رجل اعمال غني مقرب منزلنسكي الحديث هنا
عن ايغور كولوميسكي وهذا للاشتباه في
تورطه في قضايا احتيال وغسيل للاموال